I have spent my life
trying to protect my family.
The battle begins today.
♪♪
Do you remember
what it felt like
to live in peace?
The world has changed.
♪♪
This new weapon,
more powerful
than you can imagine.
It will kill thousands.
They'll fight...
Just death.
Fire!
♪♪
My queen,
the Trivantians now can
destroy entire cities.
All of Paya
will be ours.
We now have the greatest
weapon this world
has ever known.
No religion will stop it.
War is quite
an elegant solution.
I am your queen!
♪♪
My sister hunted
us for 17 years,
and she won't stop now.
I will die before I
allow anything happen to you,
or to our children.
♪♪
I never had to
fight for my crown.
Now that crown will
be forced into the
burning flames of war.
♪♪
I will be a queen of war.
You know in your heart
what needs to be done.
♪♪
Hit them again.
This moment,
this is the moment for
which you were born.
♪♪